and they easily come in the door and get
on the floor despite the fact that
marijuana has been prohibited for
decades cannabis cultivators and
enthusiasts have created a robust
culture around the plant that often for
me it's American popular culture tasty
strawberries this is story cough
Strawberry Cough is one of the most
celebrated marijuana strains in the u.s.
today the strain has won multiple awards
including best flower in the United
States at the 2013 High Times Cannabis
Cup and it's also listed on the top 40
strongest strains of all time hello
there girls Kyle kushman a master grower
and the former cultivation editor for
High Times Magazine is the man who
brought Strawberry Cough to the masses
an easy way to to determine if you have
the true Kyle kushman Strawberry Cough
is simply rubbing the stem a little bit
and giving it a little smell and it
should smell pretty notably like
strawberries and if you're looking for
the best quality Strawberry Cough your
best bet is to go to the source the buds
and roses collective where Cushman is
teamed up with Aaron Justus and Tyler
Wadley to bring high quality cannabis to
medical marijuana enthusiasts in Los
Angeles the Strawberry Cough story began
back in the year 2000 when Cushman met a
young and novice grower in Connecticut
he says will you come look at my garden
I said sure so he takes me down the
stairs from his kitchen down into his
basement and I witnessed now one of the
weakest saddest looking personal Gardens
I'd ever seen in my life
I was like yeah I do this and I do this
and I'm like yeah so I'm like leaving
and I'm on my way up the stairs and he
says he says hey calm why don't you take
this with you and I turn around and it's
a little Dixie cup the tiniest little
clone says a strawberry crop corn I want
you to take this I really took it just
to be polite put it in a brown paper
lunch bag put it on the floorboard of my
car drove home three hours to New York
City to Brooklyn brought it in the house
put on my kitchen table and I took it
out I was gonna throw it away
took it out oh no way
the bag smelled like a fresh pint of
strawberries and within two years
because it was a strain that was given
to me we freely shared it it became the
number one selling strain in the New
York delivery service area a few years
later Cushman decided to move to
California so he could grow pot legally
I loaded up a Buick Park Avenue ultra
with a trunk full of clones and gave him
out in cities are all along the drive
and became Johnny hemp seed of the
Strawberry Cough clone after Cushman ran
into justice and Wadley of the 2009
normal conference in San Francisco they
all drove to Cushman's home in Mendocino
County to trim the latest harvest it was
similar to the experience of going to
Amsterdam the first time it was it was
so I was so stoned like I was just like
sinking in and just about to go to sleep
he's like I'm gonna roll this strawberry
strawberry crop up real quick roll a big
fat joint Strawberry Cough as soon as we
started smoking it all of a sudden I'm
like eyes are starting to open I'm up
I'm walking around I'm like doing this
I'm telling stories I'm so excited I'm
like and it just totally just took me
out of that whole couch lock mood you
know that energy will be 20 kids in 100
so it can it go that much faster
basically at the time you know we were
looking for our niche in the industry
and what exactly we were going to do and
when we connected with Cushman it was
really obvious like you know this guy is
a master master
- Boehner his you know his product is
just beyond anything I've ever seen
before and this should be available to
patients across the state
Tyler moved up to Mendo when his wife
was pregnant moved into a house around
the corner for me and we just started
gardening everyday and then the cops
raided Cushman's home all of a sudden
like all these just big Ranger like just
jacked-up police officers come with
automatic rifles after a year-long
ordeal
Cushman got off with probation but the
raid ultimately proved to be extremely
costly Cushman had already started the
the Cushman genetic breathing at that
point and had a lot of seeds various
seeds crosses 7 years 7 years then they
came in took it all and poured it all in
the one container I'm good to start over
but you know we had just basically start
over again
so today buds and roses is striving to
produce the best flowers possible for
the high-end market they're building
their own seed bank hand watering their
plants and properly curing the dried
flowers in glass even Strawberry Cough
is getting a facelift over the past 15
years the strain has gotten a little bit
less vigorous it has nothing to do with
a potency it's just that the strain
itself has gotten weak so after a lot of
years of crossing Strawberry Cough with
a lot of things and coming up with
things that just are just not as good we
finally found something that we think
can live up to the Strawberry Cough name
we've crossed it with our cherry Lopez
and across the back to the Strawberry
Cough we ended up with a strain we were
calling a super Strawberry Cough and we
call it super strawberry Kafka is kind
of like Superman many marijuana lovers
are concerned that one spot is legalized
big corporations will flood the market
with low quality cheap pot that will put
the artisans out of business people who
have never smoked marijuana are gonna
have a party in their office and they're
gonna go in and go buy a package of
wacky tabacky but like the craft brewers
who are currently thriving in a market
dominated by big corporations the guys
at Budds and roses aren't concerned we
have been able to kind of be smaller
here so we've been able to focus on
quality over
they're not going to be able to destroy
the culture and the culture is
ultimately going to win that's what I
believe
[Music]